alright so we got was the name of this
one free city once again I got my so
Jason and Jory uh you know if she looks
um isn't she hot she is a nice bit of
I'm not gonna lie is very ya know
I love the way you and your wife get
along like that look at the way you look
at each other's eyes so cute let's talk
about freak City um so this is one where
they wait hmm eat
go show your wife see how she reacts to
feed eat see now that's a lot that we
will let you do that I think that's
really cool um but okay so now I get
Magic Man well and and I love the way he
says so he starts off as this beggar
like what's it looking for sugar yeah
well you aim for anything yeah anything
so so it gives them fingers of a sugar
cube think he's gonna turn to like an
elf or something to give some sort of
reward and they just like you know I'm
not really a big guy really and just
transforms into this really colorful
flamboyant Magic Man that's alright
could use for it Eddie's just yeah just
any Tigers they're just magic man it
just really maybe laughs um it was just
the last thing I expected to come out of
that - yeah cuz I'm thinking it's gonna
be something like walk it's gonna be
against what Finn is expecting like okay
so it can't be an elf or something like
you know really nice okay I'm thinking
is gonna be something even more
threatening yeah I like yeah just this
bright colorful flamboyant person there
so no I thought was really funny turns
him into a foot and again well if you
were to tell someone design Finn as a
foot you think like oh just like a big
foot maybe fins face I said but no it's
like on the upper it's a big flip on
upper right side is the rest of Finn's
body or Lisa's waist up and then his
shorts are around two of the toes and
it's like that is just so bizarre it's
like it's I really
they just had to the design team there I
just designed this and they come up with
that or if like the person writing it's
like no no it has to be designed this
way this strange way um I like that one
of us so if you tie a few ago where they
he was hanging on to the balloons and
all the boys had the same simple faith
the da dies and the smile and then one
was like really specific he has sort of
a crooked nose a couple wrinkles and he
stick eyebrows it's no reason he has
there's no other reason for him to stick
out or I think he just had that face
yeah so stuff like that is just really
fun and really wild and random um
but yeah so it comes across a bunch of
other people I came across the Magic Man
and were transformed into like an arm or
leg a waist
uh and michael dorsals yeah tonsils of
Michael Doran was the was he at oh is
that what that was
I don't know I'm just really I don't
think they ever said what he was but
yeah but my old Owen is they're kinda
nice to hear it's got somewhere I always
thought his normal voice was kind of the
wharf voice does every single time I
hear my mother's stuff - voiceover it's
like it's always that voice I'm in a
minute wait that's Worf yeah they work
yeah oh no it's just 20 there's at least
two other Star Trek next gen voice
actors that appear later on and the Star
Wars with Mark Hamill yeah but that's
kind of funny now that's three from next
gen interesting ya know but ya know I'm
like even wiper time talking normal
voice I thought was really deep like
that but here it sounded a little bit
more like I don't say a comment voice
but more human less Worf
let's Klingon I guess um and it sounds
kind of nice to hear more of a normal
voice yeah um and they band together a
Finn does the auto-tune voice again
which I for some reason I never get
tired of I think it's just like this
really I don't know what it is it's
almost meditative like I can just listen
to those sounds like some sounds you
really really like and that's just
something about Finn's auto-tuned voice
I'm currently like oh I was like in they
weren't doing the music
they weren't going into an actual song
it's just him talking in the other and
no reason right there's no segue into
he's just now he's talking like this
well he was having a dream and he's like
no I'm not gonna be this way I'm in
actually gonna get everyone happy and
together so that and they later Lee gets
them together they form this big like a
bear term body yeah and they find the
Magic Man they learned their lesson is
that there's no lesson to be learned I
guess to me it's that the Magic Man is
just a jerk yeah like that's Isis is
that he we're jerks you're Jake said
just don't give sugar to jerks yeah and
oh and then that really great joke at
the end or he's like I just I always
wanted to be a foot it's like why do I
be a foot is like oh you'll understand
when you're older and I'm really
wondering now like kids watching the
show are gonna go to like their parents
would be like mom dad we might be a foot
what a picture time said when you grow
up you understand why other people want
to be a foot and I just love to see the
look on the parents face and their
answer for that because that will
probably lead to a lot of therapy bills
in the future yeah well they could just
come on the show and sit in person well
yeah and talk about why they want to be
a foot or why they were afraid of feet
that's true and or why they can't ride a
foot and or why they see feet backwards
sometimes and it'll be swimmin feet yeah
and it'll be great but you know they'll
probably be an episode swimming in feet
I mean it's just that random and strange
well yes they're okay don't tell me so
okay so I actually loved
I think the character's name was Trudy
if I remember right or was it no I
remember the one that was like when a PR
when they finally had the magic man
under the foot and she just goes and
it's so like dark she's like the eyes
got him in the eyes my fat yeah I think
her introduction to us I just says the
Nate I think she's like hugging and
kissing a can I think it's just like
it's like that's our introduction it's
like yet everything she said was friggin
hilarious I don't like her yeah it's
like if you were to read the line they
like be okay like funny but it's like
the way she says that the delivery is so
strange and so sort of mumbled and
matter-of-fact it's really funny yeah so
yeah Magic Man was pretty funny yeah I
guess every time you transform that made
me laugh
um just straightforward pretty funny
episode doesn't it does Magic Man come
back did you want him to come back cuz
if you want Magic Man to come back he
will come back for you I do want him to
come back then he will come back for you
will you say that Joey
Jori Jori
don't move your foot at me come on
Jory get used to it normally she tends
to ignore people this is what you don't
need to get you just said we were
getting along so well yeah but that was
in the past this is the current than now
shall we divorce kitty mmm
Joey's a cat no that's my nickname poor
oh okay so Jory you got anything oh shut
down yeah this is why I never have her
on here she can't swim she can't hold a
conversation clearly man's pretty that's
true she's really done wonders with her
hair yeah
it's grown out a bit so that kind of
yeah it has grown all over her body but
it's acceptable keeps you warm at night
should we actually talk about the
episode anymore just how hot Joey is I
mean there's I I could talk about the
episode but she's given me the eye
yeah the whole I'm gonna go to sleep now
mm-hmm you just playing that yeah she's
playing like oh I'm sleepy oh I hope
someone will
watch me while I sleep the way she
throws her laugh like that - that's
really impressive are you cheating on me
she can't look you in the face that
question well it hurts anything else in
the episode I'm distraught okay we'll
see you next episode probably probably
not jewelry I'm looking at the saddest
image I've ever seen